Ezra is with us in Michigan hi Ezra how
are you good how are you Dave better
than I deserve
what's up so my wife has been debt free
for a couple weeks now a seven-speed
step to us we were planning on finishing
up baby step three about the end of next
month so I should have our emergency
fund and the thing is yeah thank you is
that we're both pretty young I'm 21
she's 23 and we don't really want to buy
a house I know a lot of people do baby
steps 3b to stay for a down payment
but we really just kind of want to rent
for a long time maybe you know like up
to ten years and perhaps to reevaluate
but by that point we should be able to
have enough state to pay cash for either
a small house or a condo and so we're
thinking of getting a little bit nicer
of an apartment it's nothing extravagant
it's still around 25% of our take-home
pay but we I'm just wondering is it that
bad of an idea to not want to buy for a
long time even though technically I
could get one sooner because we just
kind of want to travel and don't really
want the hassle of owning a house it's
not a UH it's not the end of the world
as a lifetime decision it's not a good
decision but you're very very young
getting started you got plenty of time
and you know you're talking about buying
a home probably by the time you're 30 is
what you're saying and that's fine I
don't have any issue with that I don't
want you going to decades without it
because the house goes up in value and
as houses go up in value rents go up in
value so during this a during this ten
years that you're talking about not
owning a home your rents going to go up
substantially because rents always
increases real estate values increase
and and that that's a never-ending thing
so you don't want to do that from now
until 80 years old because the increases
in the rent will limit hamper
mathematically your ability to build
wealth but on the short term it's not
the end of the world and there's no you
know you know people jump up and down
they get all get the fever and they
all upset because you've been married
for 20 minutes and hadn't bought a house
I'm not one of those I'm with you I'm
okay if you take it easy take some time
save some money Travel don't want to own
a house right now don't want to cut
grass right now don't want to deal with
that right I'm okay with that
but I don't think I would go much past
30 in your situation because you're
going to be able to afford like you said
to pay cash for something by then that
make sense to you yeah that means yeah
so it's not the end of the world but I
think your your 10 year number is the
that's the edge
I wouldn't go past that just because
past that it's starting to hamper your
ability to build wealth because as rince
cries see when you buy a house you're
rentin go up anymore that's it and the
value of the house is going up from that
on so you've clocked in one of your
biggest expense items in your budget and
it doesn't increase any more and that's
that's really wonderful
so with that in mind you may even want
to do an interim step and get you a
little condo where you don't have to
worry about it much like you don't have
to worry about an apartment and you
could do that in a few years but if you
rent for a few years or even don't buy
for ten years and save up and pay cash
for a house before you're 30 I'm I'm on
your team let's do that